AMAR RAOL: Welcome on
the Google Cloud Next.
It's a pleasure to see you all.
Hope you guys had a
really good morning.
Was that exciting, the keynotes?
Yeah?
The Googlers were
not allowed in,
so I have to rely on
your reaction here.
Thank you for coming
to our session.
My name is Amar Raol.
I'm from our professional
services organization
here in Google Cloud.
It's our team's
responsibility to help
our customers come
onto our platform
as successfully as possible.
So I'm joined today by
Heather Traher, who's
from our user research team,
and also Flint Waters, also
on our professional
services organization.
And what we want to take you
through in this next hour
is a typical journey
that our customers
go through when they're
moving from a legacy
environment for messaging and
collaboration onto G Suite.
So I wanted to give you a
very in-depth overview of what
that journey looks like, how
we actually bring customers
in successfully, what are
the strategies and the tools
that we and our partners
actually employ when we're
working with our customers,
and try and give you
some comfort on how to
make that transition
happen if you yourselves were
considering a move to G Suite.
Heather will actually
take you through how
we engage with the long-term,
once you're onto our platform,
and Flint will kind
of give a eyewitness
account of his
transition when he
was the CEO of the
State of Wyoming.
So let's get started.
I think one of the key things
I want you to understand
is we've been doing this
for a very long time.
I've been with Google now for
over five and a half years,
deploying customers onto
our platforms for both G
Suite and GCP.
These are exclusively
customers who are on G Suite.
Now they're certainly evaluating
other parts of our Google
Cloud, but you can recognize
some of these logos.
These are very large, complex,
multi-national organizations.
Not a single one of them
is a digital native.
Right, it's not just a
Snapchat or a Spotify.
These are traditional
customers who
were looking for transformation
in their business
and how they collaborated
with each other,
how their staff worked with each
other, and what sorts of tools
they can enable their staff
with in their move to the cloud.
So I want to give that idea
that this is no longer a domain.
G Suite it is no longer a domain
for small companies, SMBs.
We work with very
large organizations
in that transition and
certainly, you can do this too.
So let me take you through what
a typical journey would look
like and what are the strategies
we employ to help customers
like this move to our platform.
So our whole approach
rests on two main concepts.
That it's not just
an IT project and we
want to be with you
for the long period.
You can't change mindsets
in a short amount of time
and we want to be a partner
with you for the long haul.
So let's dive into these two
specific concepts and that
will make up our methodology
when it comes together.
So first, when we actually
deploy the G Suite
set of tools with
a large customer,
we go with the tried and true
process of people, process,
and technology, and
make sure that we
address each of those concepts.
So the technology bit is
the technical components
to actually flip the
switches into bringing
your staff into the cloud.
That could be the
messaging environment.
So if you start now, you go from
a legacy messaging environment
to using Gmail as your primary
corporate email system,
and also our
collaboration tools.
So using Docs, and
Drive, and Hangouts.
So I'll cover that in
a very specific way
and how we actually do
the technical rollout.
The people component of this
is the changed management.
This is how do you make people
aware of the change that you're
about to deploy, how do
you communicate, how do you
train them and the
options and the strategies
that you use there.
So I'll go into that in a
little bit of detail as well.
But the important
piece that we've
evolved our methodology
into is that third bucket,
which is the process.
We didn't just want to
deploy the technical tools
and then cut and run.
We wanted to work with
our staff at organizations
and make sure that
they were applying
those tools effectively in their
everyday business processes.
That's a very important
concept for us
and we have a
number of strategies
to go deeper into that, so
I'll talk to that as well.
And together, we feel that
if you address all three
of these components,
the organization that's
looking for that
true transformation
can really reach those goals.
That second concept was
around the long-term.
Our methodology does not stop
at the technical deployment.
We want to work with
you for the long haul.
So in that, our
approach actually
includes things how do you
measure how successful you
are in Google?
What sort of impact
are you having?
What sort of access
can we give you
to our road maps and our
future vision for the tools,
and how can you apply them
back into your organization?
So we'll talk a little
bit about that as well.
So when you bring these two
concepts together, you in fact,
get what our
methodology actually
is for deploying G Suite at
medium to large customers.
Certainly, all of these
concepts can be scaled
to small businesses as well.
But this is a deep methodology.
There's lots of detail
behind it and I'll
take it through just some key
concepts in each of these.
I'll focus on the middle
three, the people, process,
and the technology, and we'll
go through that very quickly.
So the technology component.
I'll work my way up.
The toolset is a deep platform.
It's a very important
concept that if you
are evaluating a
move to G Suite,
it is not just a messaging move.
We're not just talking
about mail and calendar.
We're talking about a number of
tools that are available to you
now once you come
onto that platform,
and it's an important
concept to think about
because there's lots of
opportunities around the legacy
environments that you can
displace if you were to come
onto a platform this rich.
So you see on the
left there, when
we work with our customers,
we're be talking about not only
mail and calendar, but
how they manage contacts,
how they get access through
mobile, the Docs, and Drive,
and the collaboration suite.
These are the productivity
tools that are made available.
The communication
tools that are also
available through Hangouts.
The method by which you
access using Chrome and so on.
So those are also there.
The platform also includes
our e-discovery toolset
as well, which is Vault.
So if you have environments
right now that need to do
discovery and compliance,
you can achieve those goals
using the G Suite platform.
We also have options around
data loss prevention,
how you actually authenticate
with the toolsets.
So there's lots of detail
there that you can evaluate on
whether you want to use
Google's authentication,
or if you want to use your
own SSO, or a third party.
Those are there if you
want to use two factor
authentication or keycards.
These things are made available
to you using the platform.
So it's a very flexible
platform and we
make sure that its
clear to the team
that this is a fully
cloud environment.
Right?
Its much easier to deploy,
maintain, and manage.
All of these tools here, in
fact, all work in the browser.
There's nothing
for you to install
except for that browser.
Now, we've supported all the
major modern browsers here
with our toolset.
Also, if you think about
the concept of the data
that you're generating when
we're talking about messaging
and productivity, when all
of that data is in the cloud,
you actually have a more
comprehensive data management
solution as well.
So when you need to do
compliance all your data is--
you're actually doing
compliance on the data
where it's being created
and where it's being stored.
You don't have to shimmy things
around in multiple environments
to create some of that
logic for your policies.
So that's an important
concept as well.
So think about the
G Suite environment
as a full suite of
tools that go well
beyond just mail and calendar.
OK?
The other thing is
that when you're
coming onto our
environment, we want
to make sure that you're
aware of all the things
that our teams will
actually take it
through for that migration.
These are the 10 topics that we
will cover during a migration
to G Suite.
Our partners and Google
will work with you
on each of these topics, and if
you're a medium sized business
or a large, complex
organization like the logos
that I spoke through,
these are essentially,
the technical work streams
that we will go very deeply
into as we do this migration.
So the point here is that
you should feel reassured
that yes, you will
have applications
in your current environment
that rely on mail.
We will talk through those
through an integration work
stream.
You'll want to know
OK, how do I get
to these systems
with mobile devices?
How do I set up my mobile
fleet in my environment?
We'll talk through that
in the mobile work stream.
How do I set up the policies,
and make the lawyers happy,
and address compliance issues?
We'll talk through that
in the Vault work stream.
We'll set those policies up.
So if we can tackle
these 10 items with you,
this is a successful transition
to the cloud with G Suite.
I want to zoom in a little
bit now that we're talking
about the technology component.
I want to zoom in on
the middle piece here,
which is the enablement piece.
This is the part where we
actually do the technical move
to G Suite.
We do it typically in three
steps, core IT, early adopters,
and global go live.
And these three steps
are very methodical,
especially when it comes
to the messaging component.
So what I mean by that is in
the core IT phase of a typical G
Suite deployment,
its very front loaded
in terms of the technical
work that needs to happen.
We set up our
authentication process.
We set up how we are
provisioning users.
We set up our strategy for
deploying the tools to mobile.
We'll also bring a
small fleet of users
into the platform as
quickly as possible,
without really affecting your
current environment, typically
just forwarding mail
over to G Suite.
But when we get
to early adopters,
this is our practice run.
We actually bring in 5%
to 10% of the organization
to become advocates for this
change that you're engaging in.
And we call them early adopters.
When these folks
come on, we actually
test the technical
environment that we set up
during that core IT phase.
It's the early adopter
phase that we also
switch the MX record, if
you are doing a messaging
rollout, to Google directly.
That means all your mail now
starts flowing to Google,
and those folks who remain
in Google, those 5% to 10%,
the mail will stay there,
and the rest of the folks,
they will get forwarded back
to your legacy environment.
So it's a step process.
It's a phased deployment
into our environment.
What's important about this
early adopters group as well,
is that it tests
out your training
and your communications
plans as well.
This is that dry run for when
the rest of the organization
comes in.
You're also building
advocates that
help your supported
environment scale.
Right, so when the rest
of the group comes in,
you'll have somebody in the
office within arm's reach
that you can ask questions to.
Finally, we have
a global go live.
This is where the majority
of the organization
will come in at the same time.
We try to minimize ideas
around phase go lives.
So this is contrary to
typical IT deployments
where we do multiple,
multiple phases.
In fact, we try and limit
it to these three phases,
if not four, and the
reason for that is we
want to bring users into
the G Suite environment who
work together, to minimize
something called coexistence.
Which means if you have a foot
in two different environments,
how will they work together
when it comes to calendaring?
We have tools to
bridge that gap,
but we don't want that to
be a long-term solution.
So we try to bring people
in as quickly as possible.
We've had go lives as upwards
of 90,000 users coming
into our environment
on the same day.
So let's talk about the
people component of this.
We talked through the technical
components of that switch,
but what does that change
management look like?
And I always say that a move
to G Suite, two-thirds of it
is the people component.
It's the change
management side of things.
So this is our approach for how
we handle change management.
I'm going to work on
the right side first,
which is the
communications in training,
and if there's nothing
else that you remember,
it;s the word diversify.
When it comes to creating
a change management
plan for your staff at the
scale that we have been talking
about, diversifying
your communications plan
and diversifying your training
plan is super important.
People hear and see
things in different ways
that resonate with them.
People will consume
training in different ways
that resonate with them.
Some folks will like
a setting like this
and want to be
trained in person,
and others just want
to sit at their desk
and do it in a self-paced mode.
So we want to make sure
that your plans for a move
incorporate that diversity.
We also want to do a bit
of organizational analysis
to understand who are the
users in your organization
that will be most impacted
by switch to G Suite.
We pay special attention, for
example, to admin assistance. .
They use the tools, especially
the messaging collaboration
tools, very differently
than typical staff may.
And we've paid special
attention on the training
and the communication
with them, even
being shoulder to shoulder
with them on important days
when they're switching
to our environment.
And also sponsorship
is super important.
When we're talking about a
large organization like you
saw today, at Verizon
or Colgate-Palmolive.
Having that top down
sponsorship to say,
this is why we are moving to
an environment like Google,
this is what it means to
us as an organization,
is super important.
But there's a small nuance.
Sponsorship also
includes the bottom up.
Getting your staff
involved in the process.
You don't want to dictate to
them that, hey, you're moving
to a new environment, tough.
You want them involved
in that process
and I'll talk to you
in this next slide
about what that means.
We have a program called
Google Guides and what
it is it's an old change
management best practice
around creating change agents,
and we call them Google Guides.
It's a fun thing to do.
And in that early adopter
phase I talked about earlier,
we typically recruit a
set of Google Guides.
And these Google Guides are
growing into the environment,
a month or more earlier
than the rest of the staff,
and they're given
the opportunity
to train on the toolset,
and start using it
in their business workflows, and
advocate for the change that's
happening.
These are typically
folks who are
using Google in
their personal lives
or they've used it
at a previous job.
They're very excited about
the move that's to take place
and they want to help
their own team members make
this transition successfully.
So we pay special attention
to these Google Guides
and make sure that they're
deployed out to key offices
and environments
so that they can
help us scale our transition.
Of course it's, super
important that when
you move to Google
that you make it fun.
This isn't a typical
upgrade of your operating
system or your usual upgrade
of your last environment.
This move is exciting.
I have never had so much fun
in this sort of an IT project
as I have in deploying G Suite.
Go lives have
cupcakes and parties.
I remember a DJ booth once.
You can make this a lot
of fun and fit the culture
that you want to move
into as an organization.
So I wanted to make
sure that you understood
that we have tons of tools
behind this methodology to help
you make this transition.
Not only Google, but
our partners as well.
They've built on top of
the base that we've created
and we make it super easy for
you to make that transition.
So for example, we have kickoff
templates and presentations
that you can use to actually
get the change rolling.
Even for your
communications planning we
have posters and
template emails that you
can use during your
communications outreach.
In fact, last year we bought
a company called Synergize
so that we could make self-paced
training available to you
for free within the tool set.
So when you have
thousands of users
or even hundreds of users, you
don't have to bring all of them
into a room to do
direct training.
You can give them
self-paced tools as well.
We even have a cool little
program for our top customers
called Admin Gurus.
Because I mentioned that we
pay special attention to admin
assistants, we bring
admin assistants
from Google who know how
to work in our environment
and bring them to go
lives so that they
can work with admin assistants
at other organizations.
So you can expect for example,
Verizon and Colgate-Palmolive
will have access to
those folks as well.
We also have a very
deep learning center.
So if you wanted to learn
specifically about the features
and functionality of
our tools, individuals
can go there and
learn more about that.
So all these tools
are available to you
and our partner
ecosystem has built
on top of this with
their own added flavor
to help you with
this transition.
Let's talk about
the process piece.
I mentioned that this is
a new concept that we've
been working on for a few years
and it's deeply important to us
that we don't just give
you a new set of tools
where you continue to do the
old set of business processes.
You may not do the same
workflow the same way when
you have a new set of tools,
and we recognize that,
and we want to help you
with that transition.
And that's really
what we're trying
to do when we address the
business process side.
We recognize that
an organization
that's moving to G Suite
has deep strategic goals
in that move.
It's no longer about
just saving money.
They want to speed
their operations,
or they want their
staff to be more
innovative, they want to
increase communication,
breakdown silos.
But you can't just
tell your staff
to go forth and be innovative.
It just doesn't work that way.
So what do you need to do?
You need to focus and target
on the core behavioral changes
that you're looking
for at scale.
I put three examples up here.
When I was working
with PWC, when
they were moving, one
of the conversations
that we'd been
having was how do we
move from a conference
bridge and meeting ID culture
to a video culture?
Right A lot of folks would walk
around with laptops with tape
on the cameras.
I don't know if any
of you do that here.
But how do we move to that?
At Google, we actually do 60,000
video conferences every day,
and we're not our
biggest customer.
So we have customers who do more
than that even on our platform.
But how do you get
into that zone?
And that's a key
behavioral change
that we have to influence.
The point about
using the real time
documents in Google Drive
and the editors that we have,
that really allows you to
get to insights faster.
You may actually have
a workflow right now
that requires an analyst
creates a document,
they check in that document
to a central environment
or a repository, someone else
checks it out, they make edits,
they check it back in.
Well, can we help you
there change that workflow
to be more real time?
And that's something that
our tools can help with.
The point about mobile
is interesting too.
We're of course, all in mobile.
We're all in a mobile
environment right now,
but if all you are doing is
checking your mail and calendar
or mobile, you're not getting
the most benefit out of it.
What are the possibilities
of the business processes
and workflows you can
influence if you could actually
contribute content
through mobile,
or take surveys through
your mobile environment,
or add to presentations
with mobile,
or even give the
presentation with mobile?
I should have done that.
So these are options that
you might think about
and how they might transform
your business if you think
about mobile a little bit
differently when you have
access to tools like G Suite.
One of the ways that
we try and influence
this behavioral change
is a tool we have
called the Transformation Lab.
It's a workshop.
It's a working
session where I like
to say we spend half
the time listening
and then the other
half of the time
working shoulder to shoulder
with an organization staff
to envision how you
would apply Google
tools to their existing
business process.
So for example, we work
a lot with organizations
that you may have
a HR department
in your organization.
If we were to do a
Transformation Lab with the HR
department, think about
all the business processes
that they currently engage
in that could benefit
from a tool like G Suite.
I remember we did one with
a large group of HR folks
and they came up with the
terrific idea of doing
interviews using Hangouts,
and that's something
that we took for granted.
I never even thought
to just bring it up
because we do interviews
using Hangouts
all the time at Google, but
this particular organization
did not.
And so they decided to switch
their second round interviews
to use Hangouts.
And what that allowed
them to do is save money
on scheduling the
right interviewee
with the right interviewer,
bringing multiple panels
together so they could now
expand how they did interviews,
not just one on ones, but
they could create panels now
as well.
So it just changed the approach
to that particular business
process.
So with the
Transformation Lab, I I'll
give you another example here.
We worked with
Brigs and Stratton.
We brought in a few folks
from the manufacturing team
who are responsible
for their processes
out on the shop floor.
And they had an
example where what
would happen is when
there was a question
about a particular
part or an assembly,
they would have
to stop the belt,
go over and research it
in a bunch of binders,
and then ask somebody or call
somebody if they needed help,
and then come back and
then restart that process.
And that was a very
expensive, error prone,
safety hazard type
of business process.
So what we helped them with is
someone in the Transformation
Lab came up with the idea of
let's create a Google site.
Now, creating a Google site
in G Suite is super simple.
It does not require IT to go
in and set up servers for you
or set up environments, you
just go ahead and create it.
So that the person
with the best knowledge
can create a site very easily.
So he created a
Google site, and he
started scanning
some of the manuals
that they had, and put
that on Google Drive
and linked it into the site.
So then he went
a little further.
He created access
to that Google site
on the shop floor itself
using a Chromebook.
Now he didn't have to go to the
back office to look content up,
you could actually just
go to the Chromebook,
do a search on Drive for
particular part numbers,
because we OCR in Drive, and
look up those instructions
very quickly.
I actually had one customer
in a Transformation Lab
who used this exact
same scenario,
but they went a
little bit further.
What they did was they got
the manufacturing teams
to put a QR code
stickers on their parts.
And the reason for that
is everything in G Suite
is a link.
It's an awesome feature.
So a Google Doc is a
link, a Hangout is a link,
an individual sheet in
a spreadsheet is a link,
and you can link to
these things directly.
So when this individual
started putting stickers
on their parts, when they
sent maintenance staff over,
they could scan
the QR code, which
in fact, was just a link
to the specific instruction
manual for that part.
And that saved folks from having
to lug binders and suitcases
over just to figure out
exactly what might be wrong.
So think about those
business processes
that could be innovated on.
You might just not do
them the exact same way
if you had a new set of
tools helping your business.
The other thing is, we
can't do Transformation
Labs with all 10,000
people at an organization.
That can take some time.
We'd certainly
hope you'd do that,
but we want to help
folks at scale too,
and there are things that
we call scale solutions that
can be deployed.
So I'll give you some examples.
Organizations do a lot of
project management, especially
knowledge workers.
So it's very easy for you to
create a project management
template in Google
Sheets and make
that available to
your whole domain
so that anyone can
look up in Drive,
project management, and come up
with lots of different project
management templates,
or any template
that you can set up for them.
Another template would be
your corporate template
on Google Slides.
You now have the
ability to create
a corporate branded
template so that folks
aren't starting
from scratch when
they're firing up a new tool.
You may have templates
for proposals or templates
for working with vendors.
These all can be
converted and brought
into the environment to make
it super easy for your users
to adopt.
Google Sites as well.
You can create templates
with your corporate branding
on how to create a site that
has your corporate branding
and then inspires users
on how to use it properly.
I work with the
state of Colorado
and they use this
to great effect
in saving money on
publishing sites, both
internally and externally
using Google Sites.
If you're struggling to think
about what business processes
you can impact using
G Suite, we tried
to make that a little
easier for you.
So I mentioned the HR
use case, but there's
lots of areas within your
business that you can impact.
So we've created a
website, a public website,
that you can go to, even
with your mobile phones now.
G.co/transformationgallery,
and you can look up all
the different business
processes that you might think
differently about if you
were to use a G Suite tool.
These are all
learnings that we've
gathered from doing hundreds
of Transformation Labs
and we decided to
publish them out
so that we can inspire other
teams that might be interested.
So definitely check that out.
So I want to hand
off to Heather here
to talk to you about
the long term process
and how we like to stay engaged
once you're on the platform.
Heather.
HEATHER TRAHER: Hi, everyone.
So you've seen a little
bit about the planning
and the change management that
goes into moving to G Suite,
and so now I'd like
to just walk you
through what happens
after you deploy.
Like Amar was saying, this is
not a cut and run relationship.
We really want to
stay with you and work
with you for the long haul.
And in addition to unlocking
the benefits of collaboration
and other features for
your end users in G Suite,
we also want to
unlock ways to help
you show that the choice you
made to transition to Google
is paying off.
So we want to make
sure you're are
able to see when and how
people are working better
together in your
organization and really show
the impact of these new tools.
And if you see there's
some things you'd
like to improve as you're making
the transition to G Suite,
or even just about the
products themselves,
we really want to make sure
that you have the opportunity
to give us that feedback so that
we can make things go better.
Now as your users
are adopting G Suite,
it's critical to measure
the impact on both the users
and on your business.
You had a goal that you set when
you decide to go with Google,
and we want to make sure you
can measure your effectiveness,
and we think about measuring
this in terms of these three
buckets-- adoption,
collaboration, and impact.
Adoption is pretty
straightforward.
Simply, how many of your users
are utilizing the applications
within G Suite,
and are those uses
numbers for non-Google
tools going down?
So for example, you could
measure Hangouts adoption as
compared to web sharing
or a dial-in bridge tool.
For collaboration,
how are your users
engaging with each other
and the applications?
Are they creating content
natively in G Suite?
Or are they're still using
it more as a storage drive?
Are people sharing
content and collaborating
with each other, and really,
which features are taking off
and having an impact
in your business?
Which brings me to impact, which
is once you know your users are
in the products and
engaging, how is this really
impacting your bottom
line and the users day
to day experience?
So here you're going
to want to look
at the productivity,
collaboration,
flexibility, and where people
are getting their work done,
and the device are using
to get that work done,
and even innovations in how they
feel they are doing their jobs.
So you're going to find a lot
of that data in the C panel.
You can also leverage
the reporting API,
and analyze data in BigQuery,
and create visualizations
in Data Studio.
For that rich use case
and satisfaction data
I was mentioning, you
could turn to Google Forms
and create a survey
to really understand
how your end users are
feeling about the tools.
Are they feeling as though
they're working faster?
Are they proud of the workflows
that they've developed?
We've observed in
a lot of customers
that we've worked with,
that on average, employees
have felt they've saved
upwards of two hours
a week once they switch to these
tools, which in aggregate is
actually quite a big deal
and it can be a great data
point for you proving
the case of going
Google being a success.
Amar said it, I'm
going to say it again.
We're here as your
long-term partner.
So when you go
live with G Suite,
you're added automatically
to a community
of your peers, the
Cloud Connect Platform,
where you're going to
meet other customers who
are trying to solve
similar problems,
as well as meet
Googlers who are going
to interact with you
there on a regular basis.
Our teams also provide
opportunities for networking
and problem solving
through in-person meet-ups,
through advisory boards,
and opportunities
to try out new features
and provide early feedback.
We have user research programs,
early access, trusted tester
programs.
And we want to come to you
to learn as much as we can
about your use cases and
have your needs really
influence our product roadmap.
I want to take a minute
to talk a little bit more
about our user experience team.
That's the team where
I spend my days.
So across G Suite
we have a large team
of both qualitative and
quantitative researchers
who are embedded on
the product team.
They work day to day
with design, engineering,
and product management
teams, and really the goal
is to have them function
as the voice of our users
or our customers as we're
designing and executing
our new features.
Our teams really
focus on understanding
the needs of a range
of enterprise customers
and feeding that information
back into the product roadmaps.
So we really want to
spend time with you
to hear about how we can best
help you with our products.
I'll take him in and mention
some of the common research
methods that we might use with
you if you were to participate
in something like this.
So the first one
is field research.
You can imagine this as a sort
of day in a life exercise,
or even a fly on a
wall type activity
where Google researchers
and other Google staff
will come on site,
spend time with you,
observe people in their
natural work environment,
whether that be a
knowledge worker,
whether that be somebody
on the shop floor,
and really just become
familiar with the key workflows
and use cases for your business.
And those might be use
cases where you're already
using Google products, or those
might be holes in our offering
right now, and we
can sort of get
a sense for what's
not working for you
and bring that back to
the product team as well.
We also do a lot of
end user surveys.
These are targeted,
simple surveys just
to help learn more about the
scope and size of use cases,
or interest in
potential features
that are being considered
for our roadmap.
Once we have an idea
that we think has legs,
we want to make sure that we do
not go off and build something
without checking
with our customers
and making sure this is really
hitting the need that we
had in mind when we
started developing it.
So we're going to do
some concept testing.
Sometimes this is as simple
as showing you sketches
and just having you
talk it through with us.
Sometimes we may have something
that's more of a high fidelity
mock up and get your feedback.
And then once something is
committed, it's on the roadmap,
we know it's going to be
launching, it becomes really
critical to do that one on
one, really hands on usability
testing with you and make sure
that these things that we are
used to looking
at, are really as
easy to use as they should
be before they get out
in the market.
So a two-way
relationship with Google
is going to lead to less time
on support issues for you
and it's going to lead to
better solutions for everybody
in our enterprise community.
So there's lots of different
channels for your feedback.
We've spoken about the connect
community and user research.
There's also the
Trusted Tester Program,
which is going to allow
you to look at products
and get sort of a sneak
peek and live with things
over a period of time before
they launch to the larger
population.
Something new that we've
recently kicked off
is our Enterprise
Customer Research Panel.
So this is something
that's going to allow you
and the end users
at your company
to have opportunities to
give really regular feedback
to Google on how
you work, what you
like to see in our
products, and again,
early feedback on product ideas.
This is something
that's a little bit more
formalized than some
of the activities
that I mentioned earlier.
And so, we'd love
to have anyone who
might be interested,
contact us, sign up
to participate so you can
try out some of these things
that we've gone over.
We really do just want
to spend time with you,
understanding your needs.
Not everybody works
like Google and we
want to be smarter about
what we can be building.
This is a program we
started scaling in Q4
and we're ramping up day by day.
And so, with that, I
want to hand it over
to Flint, who can give you
a bit of a first person
perspective on his
experiences going Google
with the State of Wyoming.
FLINT WATERS: Great.
Thank you.
Go ahead.
You have the next--
oh, there we go.
I'm Flint waters.
I was the CIO for
the State of Wyoming
for five and a half years, and
Wyoming was the first state
to deploy Google.
And I wanted to have
this image of cowboy
because really nothing instills
a view of technical innovation
more so than the cowboy.
Right?
Nothing?
Tough room.
All
Right, one of the things that we
took on in the State of Wyoming
was we have these vast
IT silos structure
throughout all of the agencies.
And in many cases, an
agency in state government
is its own empire.
So department of health,
and transportation,
and corrections, and the
law enforcement groups,
the attorneys.
They all ran their own IT stacks
and in various stages of decay.
Almost nothing was modern.
Almost nothing was up to date.
In fact, the day that I walked
in, brand new job of CIO.
I had retired from the
state a few years earlier.
I ran the Internet
Crimes Task Force.
So I ran high tech crime
investigations rescuing kids.
And when Governor
Mead got in, he
asked me to come
back as the CIO.
The day that I walked
in, they handed me
a Windows laptop
and a BlackBerry,
and they said this is the norm.
This is how we do business.
And I said well,
that's OK, but I'm
far more effective on a Mac.
And you could hear the hush
fall over the building.
It was like [GASP]--
this gasping across [INAUDIBLE].
I said, so I'm going
to need an iPhone.
And the prior CIO had already
contracted with Google
to bring in G Suite.
They were just deploying.
In fact, the week I started
was their first rollout
for doing adoption.
And the governor tasked me with
going in, doing some research,
figure out if this
was a smart move,
that this was good for
the State of Wyoming,
and how could we leverage this
to really make a difference?
His critical focus was impacting
quality of life for citizens.
And we had done a lot of work
in the past trying to achieve
that goal through technology.
So that was his directive to me.
And we dove in and
started looking,
and I made quite a few pretty
good sized mistakes early on.
There were a lot of challenges
we faced, and none of them
were technological, at least
none tech related to Google.
The tech went really easy,
but we had not really
expected what was going to
happen with regards to the user
adoption, to the scope and
potential of what we could do
with these tools, and
I had not properly
engaged some of the most
important innovators
within state government.
Now, as we took off down this
road, before it was over,
we consolidated all of IT,
we brought all those servers
out of the hallways and out
of the individual stacks
within agencies.
We brought all that in and
created an enterprise IT
agency.
We did that in about 18 months.
When it was done, we
closed our data centers.
We actually shifted so that
folks could operate any time,
anywhere, from any device.
That was a big lift.
It was an interesting
challenge to take on,
but it also really helped
cement the relationship,
the partnership that
we had with Google.
And I'll just give
you a few examples.
When we first announced
what we were doing,
the training work that
we did on the front end,
it was about email and calendar.
And there were like 13 email
systems around the state.
There was no central directory.
There was no single sign.
We started from way behind zero.
So there were a lot
of pretty heavy lifts
that we had to take
off from the beginning,
and I didn't really
expect what was going
to happen in terms of some of
the more innovative additions
we had on our team
that they would
start doing inside Google.
So if you take on
this journey, I
would definitely
look at that outline
that they talked
about for adoption
because it would have made
a lot of difference for us.
One of the things that
I wish I had done,
I wish I had gone through
and worked out my retention
schedules in advance.
I wish I had gotten rid of
a lot of the old information
that was laying around, instead
of going in and going to all
the work to load
it, get everything
built in the enterprise, and
then have folks say OK, great.
Now can you have
it delete anything
that was two years old?
OK.
I spent a lot of
time doing that.
I should have prepared
ahead of time.
I really should have engaged--
let's see, how do I
say this correctly?
Within every IT organization,
there were experts.
They weren't
necessarily IT experts,
but they were folks that
had invested in themselves
and were the best
in their agency
at leveraging the
tools they had.
And I didn't properly
engage those folks early on
and I should of.
Now, when I went
to directors and I
said who can be Google
Guides, well, they
gave the enthusiastic.
They gave us the folks who
were anxious to move forward,
which was helpful, except some
of the most impactful users
that could change our
percentage chance for success
were the folks who had such a
high stake in their knowledge
of how they use the
existing tools because they
had made themselves valuable
to their organization.
And when we walked
in and said these
are the tools
we're moving to, it
was almost as if I had
taken something from them.
It was almost as if
I was depriving them
of that investment
in themselves.
And I learned from that.
It blew up because
these same folks
could be the ones
that could find
the most vehement reasons
why they couldn't use this,
why they couldn't use that.
It didn't matter what it was.
It was, this is what
we know how to use
and how are we
going to engage it.
The other piece is I
failed to calculate
how much the folks
around me, my IT staff,
had a vested interest in
the existing solutions.
So for an awful lot of them,
the status quo was validating.
It was job security.
It was almost a measure of
their worth to the organization
and I needed to make sure
to engage effectively
with them to win them over.
And so, there were
a lot of things
that we kind of shifted how
we went about this business,
and I started going out and
meeting with the detractors,
with the folks that were just
certain this couldn't work.
We started running
grassroots trainings,
and I would personally
go in and sit down
with anyone in the agencies
that wished to attend,
and we would talk about how they
had established and completed
their workflows on the ground.
And right up on the front
I would apologize to them
for not properly
acknowledging what
they had invested in themselves
to make the state successful.
And in doing so, I was able
to get a fair number of them
to kind of engage in
an acknowledgement
that the potential existed with
these tools to scale to degrees
they had never seen before.
And I asked if they
would, please join me
in researching if there
was potential in here
to reinvent how state
government worked,
and we dove in and
did that exactly.
A couple of examples.
I had this compressed
digital video box on my desk
that was like $18,000,
and every cabinet
had one for communicating
with the governor's office.
It hadn't been on
in like three years.
We were spending
over a million a year
maintaining the bridges in
the systems for those devices.
And by working with
Google, I actually
got the opportunity
to go out and meet
with some of the product
leads on pipeline
and learn about what
was coming from Google.
So before it was even
publicly announced,
we were able to hear about
what they were doing with--
at the time it was
called GVCs, and then it
was Chromebox for Meetings,
and some of the capabilities
that those devices brought
to the table for us.
So we completely
reinvented how we engaged.
The governor is an example.
He wanted to go overseas
for Thanksgiving
and provide dinner
for the troops.
We had a lot of
National Guard members
that were deployed overseas.
He wanted to reach
out to me with them,
but the formal budget press
conference for the governor's
office was overlapped.
It's scheduled at
the exact same time,
and he had the idea to leverage
the technology as a force
multiplier.
So he went ahead,
he went overseas,
he handled the dinners
with the troops,
and he just stepped
into a little side room
at an airport in
the Middle East.
We put him in front of
a Nexus 7 and put him
on the big screen in the
formal conference room.
And he did his press conference.
He looked in the
eye of the press.
He greeted everyone.
He handled the press
conference and the release.
He even announced that
he was running again
for the next term
as governor and then
he went back to
doing what he did.
And that type of
shift was something
we never expected when
we adopted and moved
towards G Suite.
Another mistake that I think
I made is I thought of G Suite
as a product line instead
of as an ecosystem,
and there was so much
there that we could do.
So much there that
we could build on.
Before long, we stopped
developing thick client apps
on the ground and
in our data centers.
We started building
against Google's cloud.
on App Engine,
which allowed me to build
dynamic applications that
continued to improve
as we used them,
which was contrary to the
state's normal design.
It had been before that where
you had a problem come forward,
you went through the two
year process to do budget,
you bought a physical
server, you threw it
into a data center, and then you
started building the solution.
And once you rolled it
out into deployment,
it began to decay that day.
By moving forward and
starting to build dynamically
against the cloud
capabilities, we
found that as Google improved
products, as improved security,
as they continue to
evolve, our products built
on the top of them,
also continue to rise.
That's a big cultural shift
to get people used to.
Those were things
that I kind of had
to take on from a
people perspective
to empower us to make the
most out of what we could do.
But by the time we were done,
as I said, we consolidated IT.
We closed our data centers.
We started investing back in
those folks, those folks that
were originally reluctant
because they thought
you're taking their jobs away.
Because if you
move to the cloud,
why do they need someone
to take your cooling?
And why do they need
someone to install servers?
We were able to engage with
them, manage the communication,
and convince them that we were
going to invest back in them.
And so I started doing
cybersecurity initiatives
and training folks
on cybersecurity.
I started raising the skill
sets so that they could manage
far more deployments because
I had the cloud capability,
and I got them out of the
power and cooling business.
Eventually, they came to realize
that their resume was so much
more impactful because of what
they could do very quickly
and how they could
deliver for us.
It was a big deal.
So much so, that the
governor's efforts
to deliver IT as a
quality of life issue
were highly successful.
We deployed 10,000 users
across our enterprise,
all of the executive branch.
We did 100%.
We actually achieved
an environment where
we had security protection
and certifications on the data
centers that our data went into.
We hadn't before that.
We deployed 100,000 user
license for all students
in the State of Wyoming.
We rolled that out so that if
you were involved in education,
your district could get free
licenses for all the folks, all
the students, the parents,
the alumni, the teachers.
We rolled all that out as well.
So much so, that even the
governor's state of the state
address was led out of the
chamber between the Senate
and the House as a
YouTube live event.
When he did his
energy policy release,
that was a Hangout
on air at the time,
where people could
actually type in questions.
Citizens could engage
in typing questions.
We closed about half of our
meeting rooms in our buildings
and we moved to Scrums.
Because if you give
a government employee
an hour of schedule
in a meeting room,
it doesn't matter if
you're done for 10 minutes.
They will sit-in
that room for an hour
because they don't
have go back yet.
We changed that.
We kind of changed
the expectations.
We allowed them to
work from anywhere.
We put the Chromebox for
meetings and Chromecasts
in all the hallways and started
doing standup meetings, Scrums.
And normally a Scrum you'd
use in an agile development
environment.
We started doing Scrums for
business management as well.
So we started doing them
just for managing team leads.
We were in an old
junior high school.
It had great big
wide hallways, so we
put in these high
standing tables, and all
the white boards
and the displays up,
and then you could just
walk through a meeting.
So the network team would
be designing what we were
building our for our backbone.
You could stop in on the server
team and hear what was going on
and give input.
The day I started, the
President of the Senate
was champion building
a $40 billion
data center for the
State of Wyoming.
The President of the Senate,
well, he's a very powerful man
and I had the privilege
to go in front of him
and say with appropriate
respect, Mr President,
I think that might
not be the best idea.
It will be great.
I'll have this
beautiful corner office
in this massive single
point of failure,
and I'm not sure that's
good for us in the long run.
I got a smart bump for
that one, by the way.
When it was done, instead
we invested in the backbone
and we rolled out an IP
Version 6, 100 gig backbone
throughout all of Wyoming
and closed our data centers.
And we moved so that the
student, the professor,
the teacher, the state
employee, whoever
had the next brilliant
idea, I didn't
have to know who they
were going to be.
I just had to know
that they were
going to be sitting in a point
where they had the capacity,
they had the bandwidth
to deliver it,
and they could build it
directly to the cloud,
and that was huge for us.
Now, there's a whole
bunch more that happened
during the course of that.
One of my data centers blew up.
I had another one that they tore
the walls down on the side of.
I have a four o'clock session,
so here's my shameless plug.
I will tell the whole
Wyoming story during that,
but I ended up being such a
believer in what it empowered
for governor of Wyoming,
that after my term,
I asked for his permission
to pursue Google.
And so a little over a year
ago he gave me permission.
We separated the authorities so
that I was no longer reviewing
anything related
to Google, and I
started pursuing a position with
Google because I'm a disruptor.
I'm one of those
folks that likes
to go in and break things,
and it got to the point
that we had evolved so much in
Wyoming that my deputy CIO was
spending a lot of her
time just keeping me
from wandering the halls,
terrorizing the villagers.
And I knew it was time to
go on and do something else,
and so I pursued Google
so that I could come here,
and I now work in
professional services.
I'm not in sales.
I'm in professional services.
So I help governments impact
quality of life for citizens
and it's been a
huge success for us,
but there were a lot of
things I didn't anticipate,
and across the board
they were related
to people, not technology.
as